hello everyone and welcome to this free
webinar on bioinformatics for infectious
diseases
in today's webinar we will speak about
genomic surveillance of sars koftu
specifically on the importance of
genomic surveillance for novel
emerging variants and consequences of
large-scale vaccination on its evolution
we will also showcase some of the latest
developments
on the t bioinfo platform designed for
large-scale bioinformatics
data analysis and used in biology
studies
and introduced the upcoming omits logic
training programs for those
interested in effective utilization of
bioinformatics
for infectious diseases immunology and
microbiology
this webinar is also part of the omics
logic
specialization track on infectious
diseases where we provide training on
sequence variation and alignment
evolutionary and phylogenetic analysis
functionality and protein structure
transcriptomic analysis of
host response in this program
we will learn about the way the saskov2
pandemic has transformed our
appreciation
of genomic and bioinformatics
understand how genomic data analysis
tools can help identify
specific viral strains understand
multiple sequence
alignment phylogenetic analysis and the
significance of mutations in the context
of viral protein structure and function
we will further discuss the viral
genomes of covid19
genes proteins and the biology of the
disease
we will also discuss how the data and
the various analysis
tools can help in the detection of viral
genomes
compare and distinguish between viral
strains
identify the impact of mutations on the
functionality of viral proteins and
discuss
the biology from the standpoint of data
in this slide you can see a few news
headlines on covet 19 and its
impact that is being felt all over the
world
this clearly shows that there is much
work left
to be done when it comes to research
so before i pass on to our
program speakers today let me introduce
you to what
omix logic programs are especially for
those of you who are joining us for the
first time
at pine biotech our mission is to
simplify bioinformatics for students
clinicians and biologists and we do this
through our training programs known as
omixlogic
the omixlogic bioinformatics training
programs are running in
five different regions with over 10 000
users around the world
now let me introduce you to the main
speakers of today's session
we have dr harpreet kaur who is our
certified omix logic trainer and expert
by information
she will guide hands-on sessions and
assist participants with projects and
analysis during the program
her area of specialization is in
genomics and machine learning
dr mohit mazumdar is our omics logic
project mentor and an expert in big data
computational analysis
dr mazumdar has a phd in computational
biology and over 10 years of experience
working with industry and academia
elia prosky is the ceo and co-founder
of pine biotech in his current role he
has extensive experience working
together with
industry and academic partners who are
applying
multi-omics integration by informatics
to a variety of biotechnology and
clinical applications
with this now i would like to invite dr
harpreet to talk more about today's
subject dr harpreet over to you
thank you let me share my screen
hello everyone my name is harpreet kaur
i have a phd in bioinformatics
currently i am curriculum developer and
research consultant
with pan biotech in my current role i am
assisting
participants to learn about data
analysis
machine learning visualization in
application to the last
ngs data used in the biomedical research
to provide hands-on training and to make
participants familiar with the approach
to design
and complete a research project we are
continuously designing different
research projects using publicly
available data
based on the studies published in high
impact journals
thus we have a collection of research
projects
where you can learn how bioinformatics
can be applied in the diverse fields
using publicly available data
to drive biological and clinical
significance from that data
so let me give you glimpse of one of the
project on current
pandemic of sars scope 2 that is origin
of starscope 2.
so whenever a pandemic outbreak happens
like the current pandemic of kobit 19
there are several questions that needs
to be answered
so these questions can be of falling
where did the noble coronavirus come
from
which animal or what location how did it
start
infecting humans to understand and
design the vaccine against
any virus we need to find answers to
these questions
so towards this in the year 20
20 20 anderson at all published a
research letter in the journal
nature medicine in which authors studied
the proximal
origin of sars scope 2 based on the ngs
data
and they also find some of
important mutation in the spike proteins
that are responsible
for its enhanced pathogenicity so based
on this study
we designed a project in this project we
explored this pathogen coronavirus
itself
as well as the disease caused by it that
is covalent 19.
so here you will learn how you can find
its
reason how much it is related with
already existing uh human coronavirus
strains based on the multiple sequence
alignment
and phylogenetic analysis
based on the data that is taken from
publicly available repositories
next you will learn about what are
important components
of the virus through which they will
enter into the human cells
we will also look into how much it is
different from other
existing coronavirus strains in the
human at last
you will see how you can identify
important signatures that can
significantly different under a
different therapeutic treatment or
untreated conditions
so as we know that currently there are
various public repositories
that maintain ngs data for the sars
scope 2.
for example one of the repository that
is ncvi virus
so ncba here ncbi continuously
collecting
all the viral genome from the pentamine
and associated viral sequences
of the sars like viruses in this
repository which is also known as ncua
virus
so during this upcoming workshop you
will learn
how to obtain ngs data for sars scope 2
from these public repositories
so after downloading the data from the
ncbi
next you will learn to perform
phylogenetic analysis
to understand its unity reason
and you will also learn how you can
compare it with other existing strains
from the human samples itself based on
multiple sequence alignment and
phylogenetic analysis
subsequently you will learn how you can
perform multiple sequence alignment
to understand the mutational changes
that are taking place
in sars scope 2 in comparison to the
other strains
from different animals and human samples
further you will also see how you can
analyze
multiple sequence alignment to
understand the differences
and the mutation among different samples
at nucleotide
labels and amino acids labels you will
also learn
what are the key mutations in a specific
reason
that result in the enhancement of the
pathogenicity
of this virus
next you will also learn what are
important protein components
in the virus and the host that are
responsible for
its pathogenicity for instance
how ace 2 receptor binds to the spike
protein so here you will also learn
how to visualize structure of this
particular spike protein
and it's complex with ace ii receptor
in the next part you will also learn how
you can obtain transcriptomics data for
the patient
that are affected with the sar scope 2
from the public repository like
geo that is gene expression omnibus
here you will learn to explore this data
to find out
important transcriptomic signatures that
are associated with the particular drug
treatment
like your excellent native or
accelerated
similarly you can analyze such data to
understand how the virus cause infection
and what are some of immune response
differences between acute and mild cobit
19 this is condition so now let's go
over t
band 4 platform to see and how to uh let
me perform a demonstration of
phylogenetic analysis to understand its
unity
reason and explore the results so if you
want to
follow along go with me to the p info
server and do the steps like i will do
if you don't do if you do not have
account you can register
on the learnomics learnomics.com and use
the same credential to log in
so now let's go over t band for server
so let me first share here you can
register
yourself on this side
so this is our t bar info server which
we uh
thank you vipsa for sharing link server
link
so on this platform
you will find various sections to
perform different types of analysis
using ngs data like transcriptomic
section genomic section
then there is a dedicated section on
mass spectrometry and structure biology
then this is data integration
and data association besides it is here
we have also a dedicated section on
wireless so right now i am going to here
this section under the
uh data association you will find this
section that is phylogenetic tree
so here you will find this drop down so
this drop down have we have
example uh project example pipelines
so here i am taking the third example
example that is demo scope two reason
so if i click on this and i will direct
it to
this interface so with the start as
this is already example project so we
have already uploaded our data
from the sar scope 2 and the three uh
of data from a bad coronavirus
and uh pangolin corona uh pangolin
coronavirus
and bad sars so then after uploading our
data the next is
next step is to perform multiple
sequence alignment
so here all the sequence that ha ha
taken from different samples are
that aligned so after the multiple
sequence alignment
then using the translation codon
so then we are converting them into the
amino acid codons
so then you are selecting positions on
the msa
so there are the different positions so
this module select only specific codon
position for further phylogenetic
analysis
so then which follows the native stream
method that
you are using right like here there are
different methods like a
beast collision constant size based
method beast
special uh speciation you will process
method b speciation birth and death
process method
so here we are using all the methods so
here we choosing
where we can generate phylogenetic tree
using all the methods so then here then
we are
using the tree space method so what it
does that it will generate
eventually median tree based on from
based on all the methods
so then we have with and clicking on the
end we will able to complete this
pipeline so once we
able to complete the pipeline under here
the output
output files so if you click on this
download pipeline outputs
so you will get various types of outputs
so here you will find phylogenetry based
on the pdf files
so similarly we have also phylogenic 3
median tree that is generated by
free space method so if you download
this file
so now let me show you what it contains
so you will get the phylogenetic tree
uh like this and beside you will also
get an
output like here that is full table tsp
which contain
information related to the mutation
apart from that you will also have a
sequence that is
a line sequence in the cluster
using the cholesterol method so you will
find out different
outputs so here let me just
show you this output specifically we
have also
further analyze this outputs so
here what you will observe
so you will find the multiple sequence
alignment then based on the multiple
sequence alignment we will get this
phylogenetic tree
so this phylogenetic tree clearly shows
that
humans are scoped to genome sequences
more close to the pangolin corona virus
in comparison to the bad coronavirus
and bad sarco sars
so if you are interested in getting
started with such analysis
on your on your own i recommend
you to going to this project on learn or
mix
and practicing these exercises before
starting to analyze other datasets
related to the source code too
so let me paste its link as well
so on this platform this project is
divided into the different
lessons depending upon the objective of
each study
so now i would like to pass this session
to ilia brodsky to speak about analysis
of variant taken from
clinical and environmental samples where
we will find
variance of the concern and link them to
claims of reporting
so over to you meanwhile if you have any
questions
we will address your questions in the
chat box itself
thank you uh harpreet and uh
i will kind of pick up on where she left
off
so my name is elia brodsky and i will be
speaking about
what happened with the starscope 2
genome
since the pandemic continued for now
over a year and a half
and what are some of the major concerns
now as it is
as it is continuing to evolve under a
unique set of evolutionary pressures
that are specific to different
geographic regions and different
populations
and so we'll see how genomic data
analysis of star scope two genomes
in humans that are continuing to be
deposited on ncbi
ngis aid can help track emerging
variants of concern
and what are some of the ways that you
can analyze this data
and what are some of the insights that
you are expected to find
so we'll talk briefly about linking this
original evolution
with specific variants and then thinking
about these variants of concern
that are in fact collections of variants
they're not just single mutations but
collections of variants
that we should be paying attention to
so a lot of what i will be speaking
about is an introduction to the upcoming
training program that we will do and
this will be a program that will last
five days
so we will get a lot of the in-depth
training in the program but today it's
just more of an introduction
so in the program itself we will learn
to identify specific viral strains
understand multiple sequence alignment
options
c phylogenetic analysis and how it can
be used to detect different clades
speak about the significance of
mutations in the context of viral
protein structure and function
and then we will also discuss the viral
genomes of covid19 the specific genes
proteins and the virology of the disease
so then we will talk about how can you
practically use
publicly available data open source
tools like
r to generate a report and prepare
yourself in case you have to analyze
data
or potentially ask questions about the
nature of publicly repos
publicly deposited data sets in the
context of the
emerging variants of concern
so before we get started with the
current variance of concern that
we will speak about in just a moment
here let's look at one particular
mutation
so this particular mutation appeared
early on in the pandemic
and it is the g614 genotype
so it was first reported in february
and you can see the emergence of this
mutation
in 33 sequences deposited on ncbi
so it was really observed at low
frequency in march
it was about 26 of the total available
sequences had that mutation
but then it continued to increase
rapidly and so by april
of two of 2020 it was 65
of the sequences had that mutation and
in may
70 of those sequences had it
so it really indicated that this
mutation had a transmission advantage
over viruses with d614
right because the mutation was from d in
the position 614 and the spike protein
to
g corporate owl noted that this change
also correlated with increased viral
loads and covet 19 patients
but because this change is also
associated with the mutations in viral
nsp3 and rdrp proteins the role of the
spike protein and these observations
remained undefined
and so some studies took a look at the
d614g mutation
and how it alters the properties of the
spike protein in a way that could
impact transmission or replication so
researchers wanted to assess the role of
viral
entry and the mutations increased
ability
for cell entry so experiments with both
viral strains
so strains g614 and d614
showed that infected h82
293 t cells showed approximately nine
fold higher efficiency
and viral entry for g614
compared to d614 so an interesting
question
arised on why viruses that
are carrying the more stable g614
mutation
appear to be more transmissible without
resulting in a major observable
difference
in disease severity so it was
possible that higher levels of
functional spiked protein observed with
g614 increases the ability of host to
host transmission
but that other factors limit the rate
and efficiency of
intra-host replication alternatively the
loss
of varian associated spike protein
observed with
d614 may be compensated by greater
fusion efficiency with the destabilized
s
protein when the next target cell is
adjacent to a host tissue
so what you're seeing here is that this
particular mutation which you can see
alters kind of this region
specifically where the two domains of
the spiked protein
are connected could be raised
with the kind of continuation from where
harpreet started
which was to speak about the adaptation
process so
as you go through that project that
describes the adaptation between bats
and humans you will discover that a
particular segment
of the spiked protein is clearly changed
between bats
pangolins and humans and that is the
sphere and cleavage site
which allows the s1 s2 boundary to be
cleaved in virus-producing cells and so
this particular poly basic cleavage site
is cleaved by tm press 2
and allows greater stability and
entry into the cell so this d614g
mutation
may have emerged to compensate for this
acquired furan site
and so the special focus on the spike
protein
led to further studies and models that
could establish a clear
link between phenotype genomic variants
and to study the biology behind this
link but that's why even before we start
this training
that will begin next week it's important
to kind of go through some of the basics
if you're still not familiar
and understand what are the what
how is the genome of this co2 organized
what are the different proteins and how
are they encoded in these genes
and then what is the structure and
function of the particular domains of
the spike
protein now the variant containing the
d614g mutation has become
predominant phenotype of sorry genotype
of the wild type star scope 2 worldwide
since approximately the middle of 2020.
the mutation likely increased the
affinity of the virus to bind to the
human receptor h2 resulting in higher
infectivity and transmission rates
but potentially not increasing the
mortality or the severity of disease
variants can also become extinct due to
natural
selection for instance in june 2020 a
concerning starscope 2 variant thought
to present a decreased sensitivity to
the immune response
was detected in mink in the netherlands
in denmark
however this variant was declared
extinct just a few months later
and is actually no longer in circulation
so since then the collection of genomic
data continued and a lot of the analysis
was focused on determining
distinct clades in viral phylogeny
tracking how it changed over time
now phylogeny is different from
individual mutations because we're
speaking about
a mutational signature that helps us
identify
a distinct population that you can see
here colored
in different colors and you can see that
these changes kind of appeared over time
separating
into more and more distinct regional
selection that is associated with clades
that have become
extinct or diminished in prevalence
and the ones that have become more
established and more consistent
in the greater population bioinformatics
methods
that find individual mutations like
multiple sequence alignments
can be combined with evolutionary models
that track changes in the genomic
sequence
over the whole genome and then link them
to a particular evolutionary process
so these models and dr kaur showed some
of these models earlier
they fit to thousands of genomes and
they can reveal this dynamic
tree of the pandemic which shows that
the virus is continuing to change
pretty rapidly with novel distinct
clades that are separating from a common
origin over the course of the pandemic
so by the end of 2020 there were
approximately 12 distinct
clades and their number is continuing to
grow as you can see
there have been three nucleates defined
just since november 2020
and the clay proportions are likely to
be unreliable due to the bias and
sampling between
various countries and even outbreak
regions where sampling is done
in much greater numbers right so for
example we know some countries are just
doing
a whole lot more sequencing so the
clades and you can see down here
some of those clades and how many have
been reported during different
time periods so here from january to
february
three clades five plates between
february and may
and then seven to eight plates between
may and
the end of 2020 and so here we now have
a bunch of different clades that you can
observe here at the very end so by the
way this is
neck strain so you can navigate to that
website to find all of this information
there
so instead of individual mutations
clades are essentially based on multiple
mutations occurring
at the same time they can be found in
the spike protein but also in other
genes
so this makes it a bit more hard to
investigate
the biology behind these changes as the
complex molecular mechanisms
of multiple mutations can have an effect
on are hard to replicate
in controlled experiments but as a
result we came to this notion of
variance of concern
so these were variants or combinations
of variants that appeared in a
non-random way and this highlights the
significance of genome tracking
as we continue with this pandemic so
here you can see some of the
prevalent mutations and you can see how
they are distributed for example
in the u.s and here are some of those
mutations associated with
the 20i variant so the 20i variant is
the uk variant
across the spike genome
so overall these clades are represented
by mutations that affect
different proteins and their functional
domains but you can see here
this is if we take a collection of
sequencing data collected genomes from
various locations and we just analyze
them
we can map the mutations on the spike
protein and you can start seeing how
the specific regions of this protein are
non-random you can detect these changes
appear to be more likely to happen in
specific regions
and so now that we have access to all of
this data
anyone can actually access this data and
start asking the question
how can we detect these mutations how
can we
associate these mutations with
phenotypic data for example about time
or about geographic location and what do
we make
out of these individual mutations
so currently there are three primary
variants of concern
which are based name on the which are
named based on the country where they
were first identified
so there's the uk variant b117
south african variant b1351
and brazilian which is p1 so these
variants have mutations which are
thought to make them more transmissible
there are also early data to suggest
that uk variant is associated with a
higher mortality risk than the wild type
source code 2
and the mutations in these variants lead
to small changes in the structure of the
spike
protein but also in other proteins but
this protein is used by the virus to
enter human cells
now the spike protein is also a part of
the structure of the virus where
neutralizing
antibodies bind to block the star spoke
to infection consequently these
mutations can affect
source code 2 in an advantageous or
disadvantageous way
for the host or for the virus the most
concerning is how these mutations will
affect
efficacy of vaccines or the protection
the long-term protections that they
offer
but they're also a reflection of how
viruses
evolve under very different immune
pressures because
treatment and vaccination has already
started
and the proportion of affected people
with source code 2
is also changing so that means that the
environment that the virus is
replicating in
is changing so here you can see some of
the
hypotheses about how this virus is going
to
affect effectiveness of vaccines and
long-term protection that they offer
so you can see that basically the
vaccines that we have today
including the pfizer vaccine modern
vaccine astrozenic and others
are all based in part on the spike
protein and the spike protein that
contains these mutations
then trains our immune system and the
immune system can recognize this protein
based on binding of specific antibodies
and so some of these mutations occurring
at the binding sites
are likely to have a profound effect on
how vaccines are going to be effective
and whether new vaccines are going to be
needed
as a boost shot for those that are going
to continue
and face these new infections
in fact today we are probably all
concerned with this
tremendous spike in infections in india
so here you can see a report
so this was already an alarming report
from march
you can see that everybody was looking
at this trend but you can see at this
report in april how
the report in march right march 22nd is
about here
how since then the acceleration of
infections has been
practically exponential so how does this
reflect these variants of concern so
some 10 over 10 000 samples from 18
indian states showed that up to
771 cases of known variants 3
736 of the uk 34 of the south african
and one brazilian have these mutations
so some people have started to
hypothesize
that there's a double mutant and double
mutant what they mean by that
is that there's a separate lineage that
is developing in india with
amino acid mutations l452r
and e484q these are positions of amino
acids in the spike protein
that are occurring together but
scientifically the term double mutant
actually makes no sense
source code 2 mutates all the time so
there are many double variants all over
the place and the variant in
india is probably a representation of
many different variants that are
occurring
simultaneously or separately in
different substrates or subpopulations
of the virus
so for example other variants of concern
like b1617 from the uk
doesn't contain just two mutations it
but it's more than a dozen
so for example there is
a mutation l452r that's also present in
the dominant strain in california
b1617 has a similar mutation called e484
as the one present in the variants first
detected in south africa and brazil
and so that mutation is called e484k so
it's the same position but different
amino acid substitution so there are two
famous mutations
associated with this indian variant but
there are also about
11 other ones as well and so
the question is then is this type of a
strain
more concerning is it more contagious is
it going to be more deadly
preliminary evidence suggests that this
new indian strain
is more contagious than previous strains
of
the virus a study published recently
found that the
l452r mutation
may enhance the ability of viruses to
infect human cells in the lab
the variant in california which carries
the same mutation is about
20 percent more transmissible than older
strains of the virus
and so uh it now as this strain
continues to
uh spread in the past few months it is
seemingly becoming the dominant strain
in the state of
maharashtra sorry if i mispronounced
that but
the bottom line is that these strains
are
rapidly emerging they're very different
they can have different phenotypes
and the key is to continuously collect
genomic data to be able to identify
what we can find and then ask the
question about
what might be the link to a phenotype
now importantly these mutations
is what's been reported but recently
there have been some additional
reports that come from the efforts of
researchers around the world as they
re-analyze data
that is found in the public domain so
here's a preprint that appeared on
bioarchive recently
about large deletions that consistently
are found in the spike protein
and might have a profound effect on
vaccination as well so
this figure right here is the
identification and characterization of
recurrent deletions
deletion regions and the source code two
spike protein
so here you can see that this was found
based
on the gis 8 sequences
there are four clusters here recurrent
with recurrent
deletion regions and these deletions
are of various lengths so you can see
the position in the genome
and the length of these recurrent
deletions so
these types of uh novel insights are not
being reported
at all but they could have a profi a
profound effect
on what is actually happening below the
consensus level okay so now that we got
to this point let me kind of briefly
introduce
the significance of this genomic uh
understanding of viral trends as
these uh as the pandemic continues to
evolve
in fact there is now a national
open genomics consortium for covet 19
response
and so the advanced molecular detection
program
uh is established to coordinate source
code to sequencing
and so this is an effort called spheres
and the spheres collaboration includes
scientists from clinical and public
health labs
academic institutions and private sector
spheres
it was established to strengthen covet
19 mitigation strategies
and one of their efforts is large-scale
rapid genomic sequencing that will allow
public health experts too
monitor important changes in the virus
as it continues to circulate
gain important insights to support
contact tracing efforts
provide crucial information to aid in
identifying diagnostic and therapeutic
targets
advanced public health research in the
areas about transmission dynamics
host response and evolution of the virus
and this consortium which is led by the
cdc
advanced molecular detection program
over the past
six years has invested in federal state
and local public health labs to expand
the use of pathogen
genomics and other advanced lab
techniques to strengthen
infectious disease surveillance and
outbreak response
the aim of this consortium is to
actually
accelerate the use of genomic data and
identify these trends
translating them to public health
insight and so that's why we thought
that
it's important for us to discuss briefly
what are some of the opportunities to
identify
mutations and variants and link them to
these efforts
so first of all i'll briefly speak about
consensus level
analysis of dairy so this is analysis of
how we can find faster genomes
on ncbi and gs gis 8 and performing
multiple sequence alignment find
mutations
that are most prevalent in a sample
now there one of the important
opportunities is identification of novel
prevalent variants
so we can find variants that are already
established in the population
and ask the question what is this the
consequence of that variant then there's
an opportunity for
sub consensus and low frequency variance
so what i mean by that
is when we take fast q files from raw
next generation sequencing
and we're asking the question what are
the minor
frequency variants what are the below 50
below 20 maybe here we have an
opportunity to identify
some of the emerging variants that might
become established in the near future
and so asking those questions and having
the tools to ask those questions
is an important part of what we're going
to be talking about in this full
training program
now sometimes these variants of concern
and i'll speak about this in just a
second
are not just detected in clinical
samples in other words
you have a lot of patients these
patients are in hospitals they're
already
with clinical symptoms and there you
have a lot of genomic data
but before people get to the hospital
before they have clinical manifestation
of disease where
can we find information about what do
they what kind of virus do they
carry because they probably are the
major spreaders they're not treated
they're not cared for they might be even
asymptomatic so they
might have a lot of contact and so the
question is what can we find there and
some alternative
techniques could be done to detect those
and those would typically be in low
quality samples and i'll speak about
that in just a second
and then we're also talking about
tracking spread and emergence of
variance in densely populated areas
so the question how can we kind of
preemptively
track those variants and where can we
find data for that
so to speak about that i wanted to talk
about this new opportunity so
as you can see here the national
institute of health
grant launches study to track source
code 2 and wastewater
and you can see this opportunity is
posted on
the rfa which is to
essentially collect wastewater samples
and track variants in those samples
that are typically degraded rna at
low coverage because we are recovering
only portions of the rna
and then still the ability to be able to
find and report on particular variants
of concern so
here um you know recently this has
become public so i'm happy to share this
so the division of biomed at the
louisiana state university school of
veterinary medicine
has been analyzing wastewater samples
from different locations in east baton
rouge as well as lsu dorms in
collaboration with department of civil
environmental engineering for deduction
of viral genomes
this strategy has already helped the
university address transmission by
getting a head notice about a potential
infection spreading on campus
qpcr analysis is currently being used to
detect
viral genome units and wastewater
collected from near dorm sites
as well as wastewater processing
stations around
east baton rouge recently novel variants
were
identified in the starscope 2 virus that
increases transmission and potentially
can help the virus evade the immune
response
these have been reported in the uk south
africa
and are now expected to make their way
into the us
getting an advance notice on such
variance appearance in louisiana and
especially among students living on
campus is a major part of being prepared
with a mitigation strategy
so the lsu biomed conduct the next
generation sequencing study
using illumina my seek platform biomed
has partnered with pine biotech to
analyze the sequencing data and so
what kinds of challenges are we talking
about when we
are analyzing this kind of data now i'm
not going to be showing you any of the
data itself because
it is private but i will there are other
publicly available data sets out there
from similar studies that can help us
address the question of
quality of data reporting on specific
variants
and identification of how impactful this
could be by
linking it to known variants or by
asking the question
what are the new variants and why are
they important
so one of the first things that we
talked about is this consensus level
reporting where we can identify only the
positions that have
some uh consistent variance
that could be of importance for this
kind of preemptive
reporting for the public health
information and mitigation strategies
and here we can see how many for example
mutations are present in a sample
or how many mutations are present in a
particular gene
as well as the positions that are
present there asking the question well
what are the positions that are known to
be associated with these variants of
concern
an important part here is developing a
pipeline that could be automated and
could provide
important tools like pre-processing with
trimomatic for example and
identification of
all of the present per nucleotide
mutations which as you can see here a
brief
comparison and we'll do this comparison
together in the upcoming training
program
has an impact specifically on some of
these
high or sorry low coverage
samples as compared with
no pre-processing pcr clean only or
traumatic and pcr clean so you can see
some of the differences
here in the low coverage
which means more degradation right
essentially
and then the second part of it is how
can we report on the actual variance
that we have found and this is an
example so this is a report
a demo report provided by cosmos id
which is a company that is commercially
offering these kinds of reporting
based on clinical samples so you can see
that essentially
what we will learn to do in this
upcoming training which i think is a
very important part
of dealing with this kind of genomic
data is actually preparing
a visual report that you can share with
biologists and clinicians as well as
public health officials
kind of incorporating the important
information that there is
in the data itself and so here you can
see a critical component
obviously is coverage because with
higher coverage we have more
reliance on the data that we have with
low frequency
positions it's especially important
because they're only a small proportion
of the reads that we will find
and then actual reporting for the
variance so here
each one of these variants of concern is
a combination
of anywhere between 5 and 12 different
mutations
those mutations have different
proportions so here you can see
the proportion of these mutations that
are found in different samples
for a particular variance and so
preparing these reports means having
access to the information about variants
analyzing the proportions and then being
able to call
on a particular variant with high enough
confidence so we'll talk about
data preparation techniques we'll talk
about how this data
gets processed and then we'll talk about
how to evaluate some of the
variants that you are finding to be able
to make that information
accessible to others that might not go
into the depths of the bioinformatic
analysis
that you have performed so as a part of
this
training what we want to do is we want
to equip
others that might be dealing with this
kind of public domain data
or might be dealing with collection of
new samples maybe from waste water or
from clinical samples
to be able to effectively and
efficiently analyze it and provide
reporting that is meaningful and
reliable
and so here we will talk about different
methods different pipelines
different kind of annotation resources
that you can leverage
to be able to conduct such analysis now
this is also important for those of you
that
might not be involved in the actual
collection of samples and analysis of
samples and the reason is because you
can
also acquire important skills and so the
skills that you will gain from here is
to
read literature and understand methods
of preparation of this omics data
databases that have the data available
that you can take and you can analyze
methods of pre-processing and processing
of this data on large
big data processing uh cloud-based
platforms like the t-biome for platform
and then some skills in r which we will
use to actually prepare
the report from a table that combines
nucleotide coverage and amino acid
information that allows us to ask
questions about the data that we are
analyzing
so now i would like to pass it on to dr
mohit mazumner to speak
a little bit more about the program that
is coming up
and some of the other training
opportunities that we're going to be
offering
uh in the coming weeks so dr mizunder
over to you thank you ilya
and hello everyone so next uh we will
just show you that
what all we will be covering in each of
these sessions
so for all who are joining for the first
time my name is dr mohit mazumdar and
i'm i
i will be one of the co-mentors of this
program
so the first week of the program
we will be starting the training on may
3rd and uh
it will go on for five sessions
so these are the five sessions that we
have planned so
it would include starting from
we will go over the each of these topics
you heard today
and in great details with hands-on
practice so
specifically we will discuss uh the
trends behind the emergence of star
school two variants and then we will
talk about the genomic surveillance
where we will be discussing data
collection sequencing and bioinformatics
analysis
and then the third session will be
downstream analysis of genomic dna
so we'll be learning about the
evolutionary studies phylogenetic
analysis
uh tracing the origin and then reporting
so that reporting will be also a part of
the
fourth session where that the ea discuss
like
the custom our scripts and then about
the vaccination to
so tell you to tell you in detail uh
about each of the session that how this
will be spanned or
and how we will be you know carrying
this
session throughout that time so the
first session will be on monday so in
the first session we will be talking
about the nature of emerging variants
why they are causing concern and what
might be the driving force behind the
observed
clades or substrings of this virus so as
this virus
is continuous continues to spread around
the world
we will review some of the latest
literature and find data set examples
from these uh studies so that will be
for the first session which will be on
may 3rd uh monday at the same time
in the second session we will talk about
how
data is collected we will that will
include
uh overview of next generation
sequencing rt pcr
and other surveillance methods for
detection of viral particles
so sequencing of their genomes and
detection of variants will also be there
so we'll also speak about established
protocols like the
illumina arctic protocol that is used
for the full
genome sequencing and pcr primers for
variant tracking so this this will help
us organize data by type of sequencing
and then prepare for the analysis so
that will be what we will be covering in
the second day
on tuesday may 4th at the same time
uh for the third session uh we will
discuss methods for bioinformatics
analysis
like data processing evolutionary
analysis
uh evolutionary analysis based on
multiple sequence alignment then
phylogenetic analysis
uh phylogenetic reconstruction
as well as concepts behind the variant
calling methods so that will be on
wednesday
may 5th then on the fourth session
which is on thursday we will have an
hands-on session to load files
from ngs pipeline into r and then
use custom scripting to produce a report
on variants
uh identified as cons consensus or
sub consensus level of detection for
major and
minor variants so in this session we
will
touch on touch upon uh important
considerations
for variant calling and then we will
also be working on reporting various
clinical grade and degraded quality of
rna sequencing that elia just discussed
uh in today's session
so uh for the last session which will be
on
friday so this will go on for a week we
will discuss some of the future
expectations
as this type of data is likely to grow
in abundance
as we are all are generating data so
when many countries around the world are
investigating
billions of dollars in sequencing
variant detection
so what could be the vaccination and
other intervention interventions for
suscof2 so that will be the last session
on friday
so in this entire program you will be
accessing some of the resources which
will be
which will involve in the program so to
talk about
the resources uh let me now pass it back
to miss victor
who will guide us through the program
registration as well as the access
to various resources that we just
discussed today
so over to you if you can go through the
program resources and then maybe i can
show them the
upcoming programs that we have planned
so i will also go over the upcoming
programs a bit but
let us talk a little bit more about the
program resources and address some of
the questions that everybody has
here on the chat so elia is addressing
those questions that you have asked
so he would be addressing those now
again
for everybody who is joining us for the
first time and also for everybody who
has joined us
after say a while the new platform which
is a learn omixlogic platform
uh is now linked to the t by info
platform which means that if you create
an account
on learn.ormixlogic then you
automatically
get a demo account on the tbioinfo
server platform so you can use the same
login ids
for both the platforms so if you are
there already on the platform please
sign up here
and i'm going to be taking everybody
through a number of
free resources that you can take a look
at
and use so i have already created an
account here you can create your account
using this i will just sign in and once
i sign in i am brought to this
page where i can find
different projects and different courses
on multi-omics topics
on r and python for buying for matrix so
please feel free to take
a look at all of these projects
and today's session dr harpreet went
over this project with you
so this is the link of the project here
and i'll show you also here how you can
access this
so this project is the second one
covered 19
origin and pathogenesis of sars cov2 so
if you have some of those
questions you can go ahead and start by
studying this
project that will give you an overview
of what is being covered and also help
answer some of the questions that you
may have
and next we have another
course which i highly recommend
everybody who is
joining into bioinformatics for the
first time or wants to get started with
bioinformatics state
this is the introduction to
bioinformatics course
and there is a video that you can watch
and there are also
different lessons on how bioinformatics
is applicable in areas of
say agriculture health care also in
different other areas of research so
please go ahead and feel free to
read through this and take the courses
and besides these courses you can
actually go through any
of the courses that are listed here as
you're going through the pro
courses here you will notice that there
are some courses which are marked with a
start
all the courses that are marked with the
star means that they require a
subscription
for all of our participants who are
joining us in
any of our upcoming programs you will
have full access to the platforms
so please make sure that you are
utilizing the same uh
email id to login with which you
register for the program so that
you are given those access and for
anybody else
who are only interested in staying at
the free level of the program
there are a number of courses which are
currently available
for free for you to go ahead and review
them
so these are the resources that would be
using
and of course we will be using the t bio
info platform here
and if you are having any problem again
in
accessing the tbi info platform all you
have to do is create an account here
and log into there so with this i would
want to
ask dr mohit to share with you again
about
upcoming programs and then i have a poll
for everybody where i would
want to learn more about your interests
as well so dr mart over to you
thank you so the omics logic summer
programs
uh that we have planned are skill driven
research based training programs
so this uh so the summer of 2021 is
surely different
from what we have witnessed so far we
are into the second year of the pandemic
and all the human
lives have been affected one way or
other so
with many of us working from home we
wanted to make sure that we do our best
to bring students and researchers
opportunities to learn from
great educators to share vision about
the future of data driven research
and best of our omics logic project
project based training programs
so one of such training program which
i'm really excited about is
biomedical drug data science and drug
discovery so this is a four month
training program
allowing students to participate and
work on genomics trans economics
data and learn data science tools and
algorithms to apply
to both sequence and 3d structures
and this this training is an
opportunity for everyone or anyone to
learn about
uh to learn in uh in to learn from a
panel of experts
and mentors who have years of experience
working with
pharmaceutical companies and startups so
they will provide
important insights about the role of
data
omics analysis and industry specific
challenges
that are important for a uh important
for a career in this field
so the mentors will teach along with our
experienced omixlogic team to guide you
with uh to guide you help find answers
to your questions and gain
hands-on experience so in this program
uh this comprehensive and intensive
research training is
divided into five phases so students and
researchers interested
in working on their own projects to
learn about different omics and apply
bioinformatics tool
to the to the chemical space and to gain
hands-on experience on
modern data or drug discovery pipeline
so you can learn more about it and which
if you can share the link for the
pre-registration and the registration
so this is uh one program so another
program that we are
we are looking forward to is
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
so what we discussed today is uh one of
the specialization tracts
and the major specialization is about
learning about these
infectious diseases so bioinformatics
for infectious diseases is an online
training program
which is designed for biologists
clinicians students that are interested
in virology
microbiology and immunology and would
like to learn
about the use of bioinformatics and big
data for
infectious disease research diagnostics
as well as drug and vaccine development
so this pro this program will have
several examples of disease projects
with curated data sets
as well as guided analysis sessions to
see how bioinformatics can be used for
infectious disease research
another program that we have is genomics
in the virtual lab so genomics in the
virtual lab is a special opportunity to
learn about genomics
and big data analysis from a
world-renowned scientist and a team of
bioinformaticians working on
cutting-edge data
cutting-edge big data challenges and uh
we will be learning by dr
sona vasudevan so she is a professor of
biochemistry and molecular biology at uh
gomc and she will present the disease
associated projects
that program participants will be able
to learn from and see how genomics
is used at the intersection of data
science and biomedicine
so uh this will start in june and
another one is uh bioinformatics of
precision medicine so we will have all
of these programs
in uh may uh in may 2021 a
june 20 21 and july 2021 so they are a
part of band for
the summer uh training programs so band
format is for precision medicine
is one month program where you start
where you can learn about the
role of data in basic and translational
biomedical research
so here we will be using both chronic
and acute infectious diseases
and as well as oncology research
and we will see that the increasing
significance like how we can apply ngs
technology and
that could help and the omics data to
come up with diagnostics
and also treatment selection
so uh last one
is the research fellowship program so
the research fellowship program is uh
is a program that is built for someone
who who have already either gone through
the
learn platform and the has some
understanding about the tbi info
platform
or someone who has done one of these
programs so research
fellowship program is designed to
provide support and guidance
on development of an independent
research project
so for an independent research projects
we have a
time frame or schedule for three
or six months so either you can do a
three month research fellowship or you
can do a six month research fellowship
so during this time we meet the
participants meet with us
on a weekly basis to share their
progress and get feedback
from the program coordinators and then
they can also request one-on-one session
with mentor
on a weekly basis or a meet in a smaller
focus group
so here we work on group projects where
a number of interns are working
on a specific problem that could be
related to neuroscience or
infectious diseases or cancer biology or
cancer
precision oncology so uh as well as
agriculture so
so as we learn from all of this and we
come up with different projects the idea
is to be able to show
uh that outcome as a as a as a poster or
as a publication
so you can also learn about all of this
upcoming programs and opportunities
if you join us on our social media
groups
uh provided that you use linkedin
facebook instagram or twitter so
this is our linkedin group where we keep
on posting about uh job opportunities
as well as the on about the ongoing
program and
uh literature that is coming up which
could help you associate
you know ngs data to bioinformatics
analysis to different kind of
research areas so here you will find uh
details about
the blog post that we are writing about
different programs as well as
analysis uh strategies for uh for
example malaria research
kovid 19 research similarly we have a
facebook group where you can also join
us
uh where we keep on posting about
the new members giving them insights
about
the upcoming sessions uh which is
happening around the globe in this
online world
so where we also find you will also find
the researchers who completed their
analysis
and been able to either publish a video
presentation or a post a presentation or
a preprint
or look are going ahead for a
publication so you will find all those
information if you join
our groups here to get regular
information all the time
and with this i would like to pass it
back to
pipshot to maybe answer any of the
questions related to registration and
how could you register for the program
for this short program and how could you
go about for the other opportunities
that we just
showcased thank you thank you so much
dr mohammad so i will go ahead and
share my screen again so
if you are already registered on this
site then you would have received an
email with the payment link
that you can use in case you are not
able to pay via paypal please reach out
to me so that i can offer you any other
options that we have for
payment and all you have to do is fill
out the form it will directly take you
to the payment page here if you want to
pay again you can fill out the form
again and it will take you to the
payment page
and if you are not able to pay via
paypal
then you can again reach out to me so my
email id would be marketing at pine.bio
and the cost for this one week workshop
is 50 or in inr
it is 3730r approximately
so if you have any questions regarding
this again
please feel free to reach out i've
posted several links in the chat
so i would want to show you what these
different links mean
and the first link as dr mohit was
speaking
is about all of our upcoming programs so
if you are interested
in any of our upcoming programs and we
keep on
updating this page with all of the
information
so we have the research fellowship
program which is a program that we run
all throughout the year it's available
for either three months or six months
and you can join this program as well
then we have this upcoming program that
we spoke about today
we will also be starting genomics in the
virtual lab in june
so this would be guided by sona dr sona
vasudevan
as dr majindar has pointed out and we
are currently on the first
phase of the biomedical data science and
drug discovery program where we are
going through genomics for biomedical
drug discovery so if you are still
interested in joining
this part of the program or any of the
other parts
so the next program would be
transcriptomics for biomedical
drug discovery then data science and
finally chemo information so if any of
these
are topics of your interest you can join
either the full program
or you can join one part of these
programs
and all you have to do is go ahead fill
out all of your information
and you can choose from here whichever
program you want to join in
so again i would share the link in the
chat box so that you can look
here and you can also bookmark this page
so that anytime
you want to join you can go ahead and
take a look at it
uh so neela the cost of the program is
150 usd that is a beginner cost
but we would have uh discounts for the
program
as well if someone is joining right now
so please
reach out to me for all of those
questions if you are
interested in joining the biomedical
data science and drug discovery program
just write to me and i will be able to
send you those details
and as dr mohit showed you
we have these groups on our social media
networks and of course we are going to
be sharing here
a lot of things which are informative
for our community members but
if you're not here the members of our
group they are
a diverse number of people who join this
group
and they come from different
fields of research they are students we
have
researchers so you can actually come go
ahead and join this community and be
part
where you can continue to interact with
everybody and build your own
networks and connections so i welcome
you all to go ahead and join
and now i have a special
poll that i hope you would go ahead and
take
so i'm going to be just sharing the poll
on the screen and the poll has a few
questions so it would be wonderful to
hear
uh what your thoughts are so the first
question is
if you are interested in researching on
source code too
so if you are please put down yes or no
was this webinar helpful for you the
third question is would you like to join
our upcoming one week
workshop starting on may 3rd which is
the one that we have discussed today
and if you have any other research
interest other than infectious diseases
we do believe that you may have other uh
interests so if you have any interests
which are not mentioned here please post
those in the chat box so that
we are aware of the different interests
that you have
and you can also reach out to us
regarding those as well
these are some of the common topics of
interest that we
get get from our community so we have
posted them here
and again for any questions that you may
have
in terms of research in terms of buy
information
please write to us at any time or you
can also post those questions at any of
our social media groups
and we would be talking about that
so monica here is interested in immuno
informatics
like monica are there anybody else who
is interested in any other research
areas which are not mentioned here
wonderful veronica is interested in
neuroscience
we have had a lot of participants who
have
worked on several projects in
neuroscience so
you can actually take a look at some of
those projects
right here let me again post the link
so this link will take you through some
of the projects that were developed as
part of
our community so indrani is also
interested in immuno informatics
shinjin gene therapy sherman also
interested in neuroscience
okay thank you for sharing
okay abbay is interested in oncology so
by we have a lot of resources on
oncology so
please go ahead and take a look at
learn.omiks logic
in microbial genetics uh so go
through the metagenomic courses that are
there on learn
i think that will give you a good
overview
so monica here is interested in crisper
jean editing
okay so i will keep the pose open for
just a few more
seconds and then i'll close it so thank
you all for sharing if you have
any questions again please write to us
so shorish here is interested in gene
reprogramming
okay great thank you all for sharing so
i would be
ending the poll today
so besides the program that we have
mentioned
in today's session as well as in some of
our pages
we keep on having many of our programs
which are termed under omics logic
so please feel free to check out that
page or reach out to us with any of your
other requests for researchers and for
students who want to go into research
and are interested in developing their
own project
and necessarily if we do not have a
training program on there
we also offer mentor guidance and
support
through the research fellowship program
which is usually for
three months or six months so please
feel free to go ahead and reach out to
us with any of your questions that you
may have
and we hope to see you in our upcoming
sessions starting next week so thank you
all for joining today
and this video would be available for
everybody both in our youtube channel
which is the pine biotech youtube
channel
and let me share the direct uh
link in the chat box again for those of
you who may want to watch it
one more time and thank you so much abe
for
sharing this and thank you all
and have a wonderful day ahead good
night to everybody who are on the
eastern time zone so